We do coffee enemas once a day for years with my first cancer in 2004.
I did two a day, the Gonzalez Protocol.
No, I have CLL, which is chronic lymphocytic leukemia.
Should I increase the coffee enemas to two a day?
Well, partly that depends on how you're doing.
And if you feel like you're stable and you're doing well,
then I would say no. If you feel like you're trending in a little bit in the wrong direction,
then I would say yes. So I'm just going to go back to what Max Gerson used to talk about coffee enemas.
That's the way he would have people, and I followed his recommendations in this matter.
He would have people do up to five coffee enemas a day if they were doing poorly.
And the whole purpose of that, remember the purpose of the coffee enemas, is to stimulate
parasympathetics. They're by stimulating the liver to help detoxify and stimulating the gut
to help detoxify. And you're going to help stimulate parastosis by stimulating parasympathetics.
And you're going to help stimulate the immune response when you stimulate parasympathetics.
And you're going to help calm your body and calm your emotions when you stimulate parasympathetics.
Because your parasympathetic response is a calming response. You'll also open up the vessels,
you'll decrease blood pressure. There's all these benefits of a parasympathetic response.
That's the whole purpose of doing coffee enemas. But of course they take time and they're not
super fun to do. And you're trying to live your life. So you have to have this balance. So
he would and I have over all these years have said, you know, if you're doing better, you couldn't
trim down the coffee enemas. When I was doing poorly, I was doing coffee enemas on a daily basis.
But I rarely did more than one just because I was still working. But now I haven't done a coffee
enemma for a while. So it's the use of coffee enemas is based upon, and the frequency of coffee enemas,
I should say, is based upon, you know, where you're at, how well you're doing and guide it that way.
But you could do anywhere from one only a week to one a day to five a day depending on those factors.